so now tell me why are you not a Muslim
I'm not a Muslim because um Avery did
you say your name is yes sir Avery I'm
thank you nice to meet
you first here speak Corner yes
sir stay there can I
like the
camera everybody got everybody
got excuse me
face want
to so some people say go this way some
that way we need
room so Avery the question I asked you
is why are you not a Muslim can we come
this way no I'm not going to let the
cameras move I'm not moving we going
stay on this
side let me stop you then you can
move all right let's go
got
anotherman go ahead okay so that's a
it's a it's a load kind of a loaded
question but I like something
specific so one reason why I reject
Islam is
because um you know as a Christian the
words of Jesus are important to me and
so the Quran mentions how Jesus said
that a messenger named amid will come
after him right and so obviously you
know being a Christian if Jesus ever
mentioned a messenger to come after him
named Aid I definitely believe him I
would believe in that messenger I
believe that you know he's a prophet of
God that brought the message of God um
and I'll go with it however I don't see
any evidence of that so I see evidence
of the contrary so that's that's that's
a huge reason why I would say I reject
Islam
right so if you were not a
Christian you would reject Islam because
it mentions something that goes against
the Bible that make sense it's not just
it's something that goes against the
Bible it's saying it's making a it's
making a positive claim let that let me
rephrase what I'm saying okay go ahead
if you didn't know anything about
Christianity
uhhuh would your rejection of Islam
still be valid the way you explain this
now yes right so the Quran says Christ
talked about someone to come after him
whose name will be Ahmed and you whether
you're a Christian or you have no
knowledge of Christianity you think
because of that you reject Christianity
yeah and here's the reason why is
because if I'm I'm investigating the
claims as an investigator you know I'm
trying to verify okay is this tell is he
telling the truth here so when I go and
I investigate and I don't see anywhere
in any history where Jesus mentioned aan
to come after him I'm like oh well this
book is false it's making a false claim
you know very interesting so as an
investigator you have investigated and
looked into what this claim Jesus made
firstly where he has he made disclaims
the writings you've read yourself
yourself in in in in Greek in Hebrew in
in arama so you you've learned of all
these languages and investigated right I
I've looked into the text I've looked
into the text if a text is in Greek
you've looked into the Greek text if you
understood it fine good so so you've
investigated that the early
reports about
Christ the ones that talks about Christ
himself and you have made yourself a
good investigator a good critic and say
this kind of writings is authentic and
acceptable and reliable for example when
we look at writings about Christ in the
gospel of s Thomas for example 114
Saints on the Gospel of Judas in the
gospel of infancy right in the Gospel of
Mary none of which are in the Christian
canon in the Bible the Christians follow
today but these were written by people
who thought they were following Christ
who thought they were following the
teaching of Christ what Christ preached
so you investigated them them and you
considered so you have all of these
writings the four in the New Testament
in your new testament and the other 45
or so that we know of extent in various
manuscript traditions and you said okay
this is reliable this is not so the
question now Pines on how do you
establish authenticity and reliability
of all of these textual tradition that
is about available to us that's actually
not the question that's the question for
me to you well yeah so my my question is
is at first was where does Jesus say
this that was the question not on is
this reliable is this reliable is this
reliable is this reliable when we look
at the text of all the claims of what
Jesus said we do not where do you look
in in the earliest Testaments that we
have of his words the new the New
Testament that's right again no that's
what I'm
saying I would let just speak every I
want to clarify something yeah but let
me land this let me land how do you miss
my question no I'm trying to explain my
point but did you understand my question
though I I understand your question you
asked me how so this this is why I'm
saying this cuz you're changing the
conversation
too not that my first question was does
Jesus mention
the so where I haven't seen anywhere
where he does that so if you can provide
that for me that would be beautiful so
so this is what I'm trying to establish
okay whatever Christ said or not said
let me just remind you from if you
didn't remember there are reports in
some gospels Christ is saying something
like this I have many things to tell you
many things not one thing not two things
many things but you cannot bear them but
when I go he will come and tell you that
means whatever Christ said he said many
things but he didn't actually tell them
these disciples so the things that he
didn't say that also did he tell to
someone else number one because he
didn't tell them right like he meet Paul
in real life when he was alive he did no
no Paul in real life in real life he
Jesus is Alive in real life Paul didn't
meet Christ yes he did don't tell me
because Paul saw a vision not real Jesus
right see that let's see that he alive
um a vision and a dream is not the same
as seeing you if I see you in my dream
and if I see you now physically is it
the same it's not the same so I don't
have to even listen answer for did
Muhammad really see Jesus and Abraham
and Moses let me clarify on the night
Journey let me clarify that was a vision
let me clarify but you believe that I'm
on it's a clarify I'm making a
distinction a double stand I'm making a
distinction what's the I am telling you
so now when we say where did Christ
where did
Christ where did Christ say these things
right you have documents about you have
documents in which you say these are the
documents that we believe Christ says so
right the question inevitably that comes
is how reliable are these documents in
which they supposedly talk about what
Christ said or Christ did so it's
important for us to verify and
authenticate these documents what are
the no me respond you can respond here's
my question what my here's my question
what are the
criteria that we can use to determine
the authenticity
and reliability of what Christ said in
those available documents got you so let
me ask you this and just a quick answer
please so I can pick it back off when
you quoted Jesus saying I have many
things to say to you but you can't bear
them now was that authentic is that an
authentic it's not but for you it is
wait wait no you don't know what's
authentic for
me time time out just don't don't
misrepresent me I won't do that to you
you quot you this please stop inter you
what did I say did I interrupt you yes
you did no I did not I sat here and let
you speak no you interrupted me ear I
let you speak it's on camera continue
thank you I appreciate it so you quoted
you said in one of these documents Jesus
says and you you built your argument on
there's other words that Jesus mentioned
that are not found here and he didn't
tell you what these words are that's
what you built your case on so now when
I asked you okay let's rewind that verse
that you quoted was it authentic you
said no so then therefore you don't know
if there were other words you can't say
that there were many words that Jesus
didn't say to his disciples you don't
know if he didn't say everything resp no
let me finish so you don't know if Jesus
didn't say everything for all we know he
did according especially according to
the Quran he said everything that was in
the he revealed the inil from your from
the quran's Paradigm so he didn't miss
anything
now we'll see so now but you didn't
finish the verse he says I have many
things to say to you now right but uh I
have many things to say to you but you
can't bear them now but when the Holy
Spirit Comes Who the father will send in
my name he will guide you into all Truth
for some reason you left that out I
don't know why but I can tell you why
right now because he wasn't important
those make many say it's very important
so here it is I'm asking again record
many this is what I'm this is what I'm
asking your Quran says and makes a claim
Jesus mentioned Aid to come after him
where did he say that I'm telling you in
my turn I'm explaining to you right just
like the Prophecies of Christ himself
cannot be found even by his name even
once in the Old Testament the entirety
of the old Old Testament we say this way
the Quran is saying he was described to
them by description by attributes right
so the prophet was known to them not
only by like this is what it is says X1
said but he all known through
description just like the absence of
every single book of the Old Testament
in which the name of Christ is not even
mentioned once you assume it's referring
to Jesus it might well refer to harri
Krishna right so now let's come back to
the point I'm saying when I say Jesus
says many things I didn't say this was
authentic to me I am saying you consider
Avery this part authentic to you binding
to you not to me to you so from your own
binding at least you should say right I
agree there were many things you were
supposed to say he didn't right so the
question I asked you again which you
didn't answer is this the criteria of
determining authenticity and reliability
let's go on here once
again okay so you mentioned how you try
to make a parallel how Jesus the Old
Testament prophecies about
Jesus I'm responding to you I'm
responding to you cu you didn't answer
my question direct question yeah I asked
the direct wait I asked a direct
question and you didn't answer me what
was the direct question my direct
question was your Quran says Jesus
mentioned off mid where did he say that
that was a direct question and you and
you couldn't you didn't answer me
directly you went on waffling about well
stop stop okay well you're
misunderstanding me then okay that's
fine all right so let me respond can I
what are you responding to I'm
responding to you I'm respond I wrote
down what you said I wrote down what you
said so I'm responding you're wasting my
time what did they say I'm about to say
it I'm responding okay so you mentioned
how you mentioned how that Jesus the Old
Testament prophecies about Jesus we
won't find Jesus prophesied by name in
the Old Testament however we can find
descriptions of him in these Old
Testament prophecies and likewise it
will be like Muhammad where we don't
find his name explicitly but we can the
Quran says we'll find his descriptions
however this is where you have a problem
Manel your problem is is that your Quran
says will find him by name it says it it
says Jesus said a messenger named ahid
will come after me so I'm asking where
did he say this wait pause so this is
where you I have you know it's a false
equivocation it's not the same thing
it's a false parallel with Jesus the
Bible doesn't say in the Old Testament
we'll find the Messiah by name however
we do Isaiah 49:6 it mentions Yeshua the
salvation of Christ so we do find him by
name so wait wait so pause look here's
the here's the thing don't make claims
wait here have a discussion engage with
me I am but I need you to engage with me
so look so look you said look you said
that you we find descriptions of
Muhammad right we don't have to find his
name which it says that elsewhere in
7157 that we we find him written okay
that you know doesn't by name do you
have the Bibles 61 wait 61 verse6 finish
what you because because you don't seem
to be engaging well I'm engaging with
you directly you're not engaged with me
you're not listening to my clarification
let's listen to each other
61:6 says a is mentioned by name where
I'll answer again you do not have the
document surviving I'll tell you why the
existence wait say that part again sorry
say repeat just I didn't hear you do not
possess the documents in which we can
find these names and I'll will tell you
why because Christians have been as well
as the Jewish people throughout the
centuries
corrupting corrupting corrupting these
soal words attributed to the prophets
and Messengers and vice persons beauti
for example I alluded to you how the
corruption took place even even in the
first 400 years of Christianity people
were corrupting the test text left right
and center now what's more important
about the God we worship or so-called
prophecies here and there what's more
important oh well I'll you it's it's
really it's true like for example if if
Allah says anything wrong in the Quran
about him anything if he says princip of
God okay do do can God be wrong about
anything um let me answer no it's a yes
or no please cuz it's my turn to speak
he want me to answer yet in a control I
I'll get you I'll get you hold on can
God God be wrong in
anything can God be wrong about anything
let me answer it's a yes or no so I can
continue um do you want me to answer no
no that's okay so so the answer as we
get from the crowd is a no okay I hope
you agree I don't know you might be a
irrelevant you allow me to answer you're
so we'll see Contin so the answer for
the crowd in most Muslims will be I'm
speaking you and I'm just letting you
know the true going speak to me it's
very fa it's very fair because you won
so I need to ask your supporters got to
ask people you didn't question question
you didn't answer the question ask ask
okay can Allah can God be wrong about
anything yes or no are you finished yes
or
no let the crowd tell him ask him is he
finished it's a it's a yes or no so I
can you I I have I'm I'm asking this for
a reason I am going to answer but I
don't want you to interrupt all right
pause yeah so no so it's okay it's it's
I don't I don't want you to answer I
don't want you to answer it's okay I
don't want to talk to you that's fine
because you don't run away now man don't
run away now man come on man don't run
away now come on my time or your time
come on
my yo come on man come on
man really sh you is no it's it's
terrible
look we busted your game right if you
want to continue you just busted Allah
and Muhammad we busted your you busted
Muhammad I'm about to show you out
that's why you don't want to answer if
you want to engage with me talking
that's why you don't want to answer my
answer that's why you don't want to
answer you busted your game that's why
you don't want to answer the question
have you finished okay how about I'm
going just respond have you finished
your question no I haven't okay finish
your question okay thank you all right
so it's it's okay we good we here we
here we here we good so so the question
was can Allah be wrong about anything
mon refused to answer the question but
everybody else everybody else yes you
not W relax relx yes I did yes yes it's
a yes or no Mon it's a yes or no
mon we right here we're here right here
FOC does it
mean Focus that shows the intellectual
maturity of the Christian Crow
shame hey hey the Christians have the
intellectual capacity to answer a simple
question hey good job Christians good
job Christians good job Christi
yes
yes come on man
Christ Christ we realiz as we now as we
now realize you are not sincere to have
a discussion with a Muslim I don't think
you're sincere you haven't been able to
answer
question why why are you refusing to
answer a question I hav't refused yes
you have you are not allowing me to
respond it's here it is it's all can
Allah I be wrong yes or no man yes say
yes or no answer the question he's not
finished say yes or no okay stop there
can I answer it's say yes or no can I
answer it just give me yes look can I
answer look let let me tell he have a
verbal diarrhea let me let me tell you
why let me tell you a verbal diarrhea
let me tell you why can't finish asking
the
question of course so so here it is here
it
is I got you I got you hold on hold on I
got say I got I got to say this I got to
say this can you answer so I want to
answer now so it's a yes or no going to
answer once you give me a yes or no then
I'm going continue my
yeah I'm going continue my turn after
the yes or no I went to answer are you
afraid to here it is are you scared of
so you spoke you spoke for at least
about a minute you spoke about at least
a minute right okay but here's my thing
no it's a yes or no and then I go you're
scared of the you will carry on
afterwards so it's a yes or
no are you scared to hear the answer I
want a yes or
no yes or no
okay you know you know what you know
what the answer the answer is God cannot
be wrong in anything thank
you I answer I answered without saying
yes I didn't play your game I didn't
play his game I was able to answer
without saying yes or no thank you thank
you thank all guys your game was busted
oh you're right you're right right and
now and now okay my game was bust my
game was busted and now we're about to
see how Muhammad just got busted by you
you you busted Muhammad let me show you
how because now now watch this guys so
look now watch this so so the concept of
God is important right the concept of
God is important I got you relax relax
relax so the concept of God is important
so the concept of God the concept of God
so one of the uh intricate
characteristics of him is that he cannot
be wrong he cannot be f absolutely okay
good so if he gets this
wrong if if he says that that uh Jesus
mentioned AIT to come after him and it
didn't happen then Allah is not God in
the Quran he's not God cuz he fails when
it comes to the concept of the true God
he can't be wrong so that's why we're
investigating this this is important and
wait wait wait no I'm not okay cuz I got
to get back to what you said okay so
move up a bit yeah sorry sorry about
that sor
so look so look so when you say for
example that um that we cannot we don't
have any of the documents where we can
see or verify where Jesus said this we
have no evidence of this claim right
that's what you said we don't have any
evidence really of Jesus's words that's
what you said so we can't find this so
what you because yeah what you said you
said that you have a memory problem I I
I have Perfect Memory know sometimes I
lose my memory that's fine wor it's good
it's good so you said this is because
because over the centuries second third
fourth and fifth century the Christians
have corrupted their scripture and
that's why we cannot find the true words
of Jesus for example him mentioning that
Offman will come after him so you just
busted Muhammad where your Quran says
and Allah by the way because Allah says
that they had the injil they had the
gospel that Jesus preached they had it
with them and in that in that wait wait
you saying that we don't
okay good so what so what is the let me
tell you exactly so now it's my turn to
speak absolutely what is the I'll and
then I'll go back to the concept of what
is theil so now the inil is what God
gave to ISA what was that you
interrupting explain it you interrupting
me the whole time let speak do you have
a problem of letting people speak I have
I have a problem of letting people lie
I'm trying to help you be on track you
just called me yes I do end of
discussion
he couldn't tell me what the was he
calls me a liar he should have at least
have should at least have after you
after you tried to insult my
intelligence after you insulted my
intelligence and now he can dish out
what you can't take EXC you can just sh
what you can't say I'm not interested in
speaking to someone who accused people
of lying you accuse me of having memory
problem of of of of of messing up your
words so so you can insult my
intelligence but I can't I can't is
you're a liar is there anyone else
capable to speak about is there anybody
else who's a Muslim that could tell me
where the heck can I find Jesus saying
off meone any Muslims any Muslim any
Muslims any
Muslim any
Muslim any Muslim all right take care
all right guys all right guys say bye
say
bye
bye bye
go this
side so
guys get get get get some space get some
space so
guys well done man yeah let's hold on
let me do this ra up let me do this ra
up guys guys yeah we're doing a wrap up
guys guys this is why this is important
okay I I don't want you guys to get lost
in all the commotion the reason the
reason why the questions that I asked
was important cuz each and every one of
y'all can do it all y'all got to do is
ask simple questions and they can't
prove nothing they say they can't do it
but here's the problem is because the
Quran itself puts them in a bind the
Quran notice how he's trying to say um
that you know in the Old Testament we'll
find descriptions of Jesus but not by
name so we shouldn't expect the same of
Muhammad uhoh hold on time out your
Quran says we'll find Muhammad by name
so if we don't find Muhammad by name
then the Quran is false muham is a false
prophet and Allah is a liar wait wait
wait wait it's been
corrupted it's been corrupted we busted
you it's been corrupted you didn't bust
me you busted Allah and Muhammad because
Muhammad says that the inil is in my
hands that I have it and that if I go
into it I can find Muhammad written in
it that I can find the words of Jesus
preaching off me so if I can't the Quran
is false Allah is a false god Muhammad
is a pagan Prophet that's what we have
so what he just did was showed us how
Quran has no answers amen the most
intellectual smartest clever of them
have no answers to the simplest
questions nothing about
nothing deep just simple questions and
it was over you had to run bye mon